some weird essentials everybody has like
weird stuff yeah hey what up everybody
it's your boy Fat Joe right here GQ and
these are my essentials my first ascent
you being that I don't feel comfortable
with it being out so long can I get that
cinterion black card please this is very
necessary you can buy a building with
this you will keep this closed I think
I've been maybe 20 years with a car all
the purpose well you know they have a
Centurion Club at the airport you want a
quiet place you go to a Lam Centurion
lounge
we got a concierge service to where we
caller say yo I need a hotel and let's
say in Greenland I'm going on vacation
they put us in the nicest rooms defeated
just for the card is like 2500 or
something I gotta have if we went up to
16,000 I would be Alex black card he
sent you I'm one of the biggest sneaker
collectors in the planet Earth including
Asia man I have thousands and thousands
of pairs just anywhere from like five to
ten thousand these right here are one of
one which means nobody else will ever
come step next to you with these
sneakers on he said that's it this was
made for Mike Bibby I actually had to
fight him to get these shoes no
literally I went to his house and he was
like yo and he sneakers you want and I
ran for these so his family was like man
yo Mike why are you getting upset he was
like he knows what he's doing he's like
going to his house taking the platinum
plaque off his wall that's only one of
ones the guy choked me and he's short
but he's like [ __ ] diesel when he let me
go he let me keep these this right here
is actually the over yo drape sneaker I
believe this is one of two but he's a
gold for like 50 grand on the streets
and I bust my butt trying to get these
right these might have been the hardest
ones I ever got it's part of the sneaker
culture you don't tell nobody captain
from but I got him a warm in my latest
video yes would cardi B and
well only wore this one time to our
waters to summer jam I grew up so poor
man that I celebrated by just wearing a
sneaker one time if they're very
important I'll keep them in the status
and collect is there like something that
we could just get over and over again
I'll probably give it to people I'll
give people a lot there's a fat guy fly
in your church and he's rocking some bow
mane I'm rocking some tongue forward Fat
Joe mighty came by your church and
dropped off ten 20 bags this is a fact I
give back and then I'm like damn
somebody gonna be fly with this thing my
man no I want to win him shit's this
week it's the [ __ ] problem this is
the big boy gold edition ace of spades a
much finer champagne I get drunk on my
birthday
and I get drunk on New Year's I gotta be
like the party of the year like Diddy
has invited me to his party now fiftieth
birthday
I will be drunk I did he's 50 your
birthday you know it gotta be something
crazy last year I had my birthday jay-z
has sent over eighty thousand dollars
word for Ace of Spades I mean these guys
these bottles were so big it looked like
baby human beings I mean I don't care
who's a celebrity family member cousin
Tito I even know a guy small guy I wanna
call him a [ __ ] but I know small guy
that were very good friends with there's
walking around with a bottle bigger than
him but he was like walking through the
party with the pig we had a blast man
but this is definitely my favorite
champagne this is definitely an
essential something people don't know
Fat Joe's a movie buff
I have to have hot pop before the movie
even starts I just saw the movie Queen
and slim touching an amazing movie I ran
out the movie theater trying not to cry
but I took down maybe three bags of
popcorn
I don't add the butter you know
sometimes you go to movie theaters they
got the cheddar butter earth now I'm not
playing in today I just want the good
old fashioned you know where you're
walking that movie did and you smell
that different kind of popcorn it's an
essential and of course with the park
very important for me is a diet coke you
know when I was younger I had juvenile
diabetes so I had to drink everything
sugar-free since I lost weight thank God
the diabetes went away but I still act
like I got diabetes just to stay on the
right track but this right here man I go
to a lot of these and I know as
aspartame I know you know if anything
takes me down it's a diet coke because I
mean I'm just addicted to it I enjoy a
mean diet coke
I'm Caribbean I'm Latino come anytime a
celebration we pull the room up this has
been the latest form of choice cash cane
it has this smoke flavor to it it almost
feels like you had a barbecue myself
definitely when it comes to rooms I take
down that cash cane some French guys
they were like yo have you ever tasted
this room and I was like cash cane then
you're like nas fire
no diet coke straight up I like to taste
the flavor I can't believe y'all found
it man the cash came
this is Royal Oak ap we call it a shadow
error I remember I used to go see my
favorite singer of all time too late
great Newt the banjos I would always
remember he have a watch like this on
and it would just be shining from upper
deck and I'll be seeing him so the first
thing I ever did when I got money was
gonna watch there was just so Iced Out
but this is the epitome this is forget
and it matches the rose gold you know
that's changed and it's changed this is
a booger I went back to the jeweler to
get bigger boogers he said please you
gotta stop you know how people go to
surgery and it won't stop going for
surgery I try to go get bigger boogers
and buy jewel it's over here you gotta
stop I got that from pristine jewelers
and they're the biggest in the game
right now enough this is definitely an
essential it's where we put that
cinterion black card as a [ __ ] yard
little while it my wife bought it for me
I think for Christmas
I like tipping in cash right because I
always feel like the worker gets robbed
so if you go to rest them on you pay
credit card and then you put down 20% we
don't even know what happens with that
22 this person really get it thank you
cash we got a lei whatever you got
spread the love you know we learned that
from ginger and Casino the reason they
never turned on hunters everywhere she
went she was just tipping everybody know
I think I'm a solid 20 percent I've been
in situations when people looked at me
like I was crazy like they thought cuz I
was fat Joe I'm supposed to take crazy
money's I've seen eyes roll like he's
rich like he should give me more than
what he paid for the meal that's crazy
we saved the best for last like that
throughout my whole career there's been
a guy behind the scenes him and his
partner have made massive hits for me
and everybody else in the industry I
wouldn't be fat Jill without this guy
and I mean it one half of the super
producers cooling tray y'all Draper said
you wanted my essentials man man I'm
honored Joe cracks been an essential to
my entire career to be honest he was the
first superstar to recognize a talent
that I had along with my partner cool
I'm blessed to make a lot of history
together oh yeah shot my brother DJ
calorie did highlight me baby form
you also have an album together called
family ties Eminem's on the album Mary
Jays on that huh boom cardi B's on out
there on the walls on the hop
ten years from now we can make a musical
about this one album this would be like
the Hamilton so if you got love for Joe
crack just press play yo Dre I want to
thank you for being a dissent you do you
definitely think you fly enough to be on
GQ I mean I've been waiting for the call
but you know give I'm saying I'm with
the dawn there so that's a plus my
brother I love my brother every day is
exciting this is my essentials